rachel is with us in Washington
hi Rachel welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show how they pleasure to speak with you
you too
what's up I really want to know what to
do with my student loan so this is kind
of my aha moment I was comparing two
bills and the bill numbers are going up
and I've been paying on them so it seems
like forever and I am in the
income-based plan and on the federal
student loan forgiveness plan which I'm
not counting on but I'm wondering if I
should refinance them and be paying in
the full amount on them now well it's in
my step snowball it's kind of the top
one on my list right so or should I just
keep them in the income-based plan and
pay that minimum balance and then just
keep it there while I'm on the debt
snowball or refinance our winners you
said the top of the debt snowball you
mean it's the largest debt or your
smallest at correct the largest okay and
so how much other debt do you have how
much debt do you have total not counting
your house not counting my house I have
about 1,800 on one credit card
thirty-eight hundred on another ten
thousand on a line of credit I have a
seventeen thousand dollar car payment
and about thirty thousand dollars in
student loans and what is your income I
think about $60,000 a year and I'm a
single mom okay pretty expensive car
yeah first car payment okay and you're
just starting this whole thing yeah I
just started the budget app every dollar
about an honest good for you how old are
you 31 good for you okay good good I'm
proud of you good start
all right well the income based is never
is always going to go backwards almost
always depending on your income but
usually it creates a payment that does
not even cover the interest and so the
extra has added the balance okay so the
income based does not ever get you out
of debt unless you have a very high
income
which you wouldn't be on income-based
usually for then so and as you know
you've already discovered in the short
time listening to us that you know we're
discovering the income or the student
loan forgiveness program is a fraud
30,000 people have applied for it 93
have gotten it and sharing like three
and a half years out of time now yeah
and it's so it's pretty pretty bad plan
so anyway the we've got to have another
way to get rid of this debt now so we're
gonna work the debt snowball clear off
all these other debts when you don't
have any payments but the student loan
then you're going to be able to attack
the student loan with a vengeance and
you'll clear it up in less than two
years at that point so you probably have
about a three year plan of being about
five no you're gonna you're gonna work
extra you're gonna sell some stuff you
may need to sell this car and get down
get down into about a $5,000 car and
that'll help you get rid of a big hairy
payment number one how much was your
payment on that car and it's about three
hundred and five yeah that's a lot but I
have it on this seven years seven year
long yeah well you not anymore because
you're paying it off in three or you're
getting rid of it yeah
because what I'm looking at here is
basically I've got about sixty thousand
dollars worth of debt making sixty
thousand so if we do twenty a year if we
do twenty a year for three years that
puts you out of debt that's what I'm
looking at if you can't do that and
you're you can't get they can't see your
way of doing that in the budget then you
do need to get rid of the car but I
think that's probably pretty doable
somewhere in there you're probably
working some extra jobs or some overtime
you're probably selling some other stuff
you're definitely not seeing the inside
of a restaurant unless you're working
there and you're definitely not going on
vacation you have a freaking mess you're
cleaning up here and it's scary yeah I
got rid of the vacation account good
good it's it's scary looking at all this
and if you don't know so here's the
thing it doesn't matter what payment
plan your own with your student loan if
it's going to be gone in three years
anyway okay
so I mean you could continue to pay the
income-based until you get to it on the
debt snowball and then tear into it
right when you're there because that's
gonna be your only debt left at that
point you're going to go bananas on that
thing and just knock it out and so that
you know how you pay your debt snowball
or how you pay your student loan or
whether you pay your student loan
doesn't really matter if you're got if
you're on a three-year plan to get rid
of it because you're going to be done
with it that quickly anyway and that's
where you need to be so we've got to get
you tied into that let me do this let's
put you into Financial Peace University
the nine week class and then financial
peace the one year membership which will
give you the upgrade for your every
dollar to every dollar Plus and it
connects to your bank and you can go to
the nine week class and you can get in
the online communities that are really
supportive and you can watch the stuff
we do streaming there's all kinds of
stuff in this membership it is a very
very valuable thing and I'm going to
give it to you for free I want to help
you get turned around on this kiddo you
can do this